well the german government says it's
looking at the entire set of instruments
it could use in taking action against
moscow over the poisoning of russian
opposition leader alexey navalny
chancellor angela mackle's spokesman has
underlined that she would not rule out
consequences on the multi-billion euro
nordstream 2 pipeline project if moscow
fails to thoroughly investigate the case
he also says that the german leader
is open to all sanctions options
the nordstream 2 pipeline through the
baltic sea means a lot to both parties
for russia it's a source of solid
foreign currency for germany and other
eu countries it's a major energy conduit
but following the poisoning of russian
opposition figurehead alexei navalny
a crime blamed on moscow the german
government has for the first time
considered halting construction of
nordstrom 2.
it wouldn't be the first time the eu has
levied sanctions against russia
the number of cases in which countries
impose sanctions on others is climbing
accelerating rapidly from 2004 on
besides russia the countries most often
targeted are iran
and north korea as well as some african
countries
the main pretext for such sanctions are
violations of human rights and
democratic procedures
they're also often ostensibly aimed at
trying to prevent terrorism and war
but how effective are sanctions really
at achieving their aims
opinions are widely divided
our senior business editor ben fazoulin
has been following this story all along
ben this is really a point where germany
is wringing its hands over a question of
sanctions on russia but this is exactly
where
business interests and politics collide
isn't it and it can get very messy
it's a big game of chess basically but
this pipeline is just
a small piece in that game and we're in
the threatening period so the best
sanctions are those sanctions that are
just threatened and there's a change of
behavior but
nothing uh really happens so
it's whether or not that threat is taken
seriously
the the russian investors the investors
in russia are shrugging them off at the
moment
they they see russia's finances as being
too strong to be cracked
moscow does have one of the strongest
public balance sheets
in the world you can't forget that
economists say this is only going to be
effective if all sectors are targeted
all economic sectors that would mean
that it would hurt russians
it would hurt both sides europe as well
the ultimate sanction in my opinion
would be making it illegal to own
russian sovereign debt that would mean
that russia's borrowing costs would
shoot up
but this would be really tricky because
u.s residents own
10 percent of russian sovereign debt
europe is also a big investor so as
canada and japan and getting them
all on board is really really tricky but
i asked economist
gabriel felbermaier about exactly that
that would in a sense be a bazooka
indeed that
is a large action indeed but we would
need a full
coalition there is a lot of excess
saving around in the world so
there's a lot of savings that seek
investment and we would need to block
um you know all ways of
russia selling their bonds if it's just
europe that wouldn't be enough we would
need the united states on board on this
and probably also asian countries so
i think there's no real alternative uh
uh
to building a coalition and uh if we go
uh
new sanctions then this need to be
almost universal sanctions
almost universal the the problem there
is u.s president donald trump is isn't
he still best buddies with vladimir
putin
well you know our the economist there
talked about building a coalition
the question is how do you get u.s and
europe and those asian countries you
talked about
on the same page with uh imposing
sanctions and possibly uh imposing
sanctions on holding
sovereign debt is that do you see any
prospects of that happening man well as
far as the pipeline goes trump would
love to see the pipeline go
it would mean he could potentially
increase energy exports
to europe and he would love that but
about the rest i
i don't know that's a really hard
question i
asked ferbermeyer again about getting
the us on board
without the u.s on board it's very
difficult to impose sanctions and to
make them effective
in particular because of course the
world currency is the dollar
so without the u.s those sanctions would
be very difficult
and we do see when large coalitions act
against countries that too is a result
of
uh of the past experience large
coalitions achieve something but if
if a country like germany or a
relatively minor player in the
international financial markets like the
eu
go alone then the chances of success are
i'm sorry to say that no so it's a big
game
of chess and terry i've always been a
really bad chess player
i can't tell you where this one's going
we'll play and we'll see who's worse
thanks ben thank you so much ben bazul
and our senior business editor